vielleicht ist das beste symbol für den
kollaps eines landes der nie abgeholte
müll in den straßen seiner hauptstadt
und die menschen in müll libanesen die
so viele kriege erlebten aber in keinem
krieg so hungerten wie in diesen tag
ich esse von müll ich habe kein geld für
essen hoffentlich kehrt der krieg zurück
besser heute als morgen der krieg ist
besser als die entwürdigung die wir hier
durch machen
es sei gelaufen mit dem libanon sagt der
rentner noch es gebe keinen libanon mehr
vor mitternacht in eine großbäckerei
südlich von beirut sie kaufen schnell
auf was noch da ist weil die bäckereien
keine großen mail vorräte haben geht
vielerorts das brot aus der krieg in der
ukraine aus dem das land einen großteil
seines weizens importierte hat die
unsicherheit nur noch verschärft
jeden tag fehlt brot und ich habe sieben
kinder zu hause möge gott uns helfen
möge gott dieses land helfen
meine familie in beirut hat kein brot
sie haben mich gebeten hier welches zu
kaufen es gibt kein brot in der stadt
ich habe alles abgesucht
bei rot eine postkartenidylle
aus der ferne verrät nichts die
tragödien hinter jeder tür
war jonas eine sonderschullehrerin nimmt
uns mit in das zimmer ihrer kinder ein
stück heile welt aber der schein trügt
tochter luna ist vier und hat einen
aggressiven krebs im körper in ihrem
land gibt es keine medikamente mehr für
sie
wir haben einen punkt erreicht zum
psychologisch wo wir aus dem schlaf auf
schrecken und angst haben dass sie nicht
mehr bei uns ist für
ihre eltern ist die medikamenten suche
ein 24 stunden job über freunde bekannte
netzwerke organisieren sie kühlketten
und kaufen alois b die ziehen in
frankreich in der schweiz in nigeria
zugleich müssen sie mit ansehen wie die
eigene währung wertlos wird wie ihre
ersparnisse verschwinden und wie die
überlebenschancen der tochter rapide
sinken
wir hatten eine 90-prozentige hoffnung
dass sie geheilt wird
aber der medikamentenmangel und die
medizinischen komplikationen dadurch
haben ihre chancen auf 40 45 prozent
gedrückt
strom hat die familie nur wenige stunden
der generator draußen braucht diesel und
der ist spätestens seit dem krieg in der
ukraine so teuer wie ein luxusgut wie
die medikamente für die kleine kühlen
das ist unsere schatzkiste dafür haben
wir strom von allen nachbarn angezapft
jemand mit einem eigenen stromgenerator
schickt den strom zu uns damit dass hier
durchgängig kühl bleibt
kaum zu glauben aber für die vermögenden
des libanon und die milliardäre der
politik geht das leben einfach weiter
die entscheidungsträger setzen ganz
bequem auf humanitäre hilfe von außen
ein un bericht macht den staat und die
zentralbank für die verelendung
verantwortlich die wirtschafts und
finanzkrise wäre vermeidbar gewesen
erst vor wenigen tagen haben die
libanesen ein neues parlament gewählt
aber die hoffnung auf einen
systemwechsel ist gering
wenn wir nicht gegen diese korrupte
führung stellen als wären wir alle
sterben unsere ganze jugend wird
ausgewandert sein meine freunde sind
alle weg es gibt keinen strom kein
wasser keine reformen nichts
unsere regierung soll nach hause gehen
von der spitze bis ganz unten dass der
präsident sich nicht schämt noch seinen
mund aufzumachen
wer der armut des libanon entfliehen
will riskiert sein leben in tripoli der
ärmsten staates des landes gibt es immer
mehr tote flüchtlinge und immer mehr wut
hier beerdigten sie die opfer des
jüngsten bot unglücks
yussuf jamal trauert um seine enkel dass
seine tochter seine frau sie liegen auf
dem grund des mittelmeers zu siebt
wollten sie nach deutschland fliehen ihr
einfaches leben erzählt er sei in den
letzten jahren immer unerträglicher
geworden
[Musik]
hoffnungsfroh hatten sie sich aufgemacht
das letzte handyvideo vor der flucht
betet dass wir nicht ertrinken sagen sie
für die bootsfahrt hätten sie ihr auto
möbel und matratzen verkauft und sich
verschuldet
stunden später die geretteten erzählen
wir die libanesische marine das boot
rannte bis es in sekundenschnelle st
39 flüchtlinge starten
sie richteten die waffen auf uns aber
wir hielten nicht an ich sagte dem
offizier dass er wegfahren soll dass wir
frauen und kinder an bord haben dass wir
keine terroristen sind nichts falsches
tun nur aus einem land auswandern das
uns nicht mehr unterstützen nicht mehr
ernähren kann
die familie steht unter schock sie
sitzen in dem einzigen raum mit fenstern
ein baufälliger verschlag in denen es
hinein tropft
sohn und schwiegertochter sind aus
deutschland gekommen sie sorgen sich um
den kranken vater der sich oft nicht
mehr leisten konnte als von tee und brot
zu leben erzählen sie was jetzt
seitdem wir hier sind suchen wir
apotheken nur seine medikamente um
medikamente für ihn zu finden wir finden
keine medikamente
[Musik]
kann deutschland uns helfen unsere toten
frauen und kinder aus dem mittelmeer zu
bergen fragen sie uns ihre eigene stadt
hat sie schon lange verlassen